大家好，我叫戴维·布朗 (Dàiwéi Bùlǎng)，这是一堂读写课。
你好，欢迎。你今天怎么样？
老师好，很高兴见到您。
我也很高兴见到你。我叫戴维。你叫什么名字？
我叫弗朗切斯科 (Fúlǎngqiēsīkē)。很高兴认识您，戴维老师。
很高兴认识你，弗朗切斯科同学。欢迎。
我看到您选择了一节关于沃尔特·惠特曼 (Wò'ěrtè Huìtèmàn) 和他著名诗歌的课程，
《啊，船长！我的船长！》(Ā, chuánzhǎng! Wǒ de chuánzhǎng!)，一堂读写课。对吗？
是的，没错。
好的，非常好。
那么我来给你简单介绍一下亚伯拉罕·林肯 (Yàbólāhǎn Línkěn)。
你可能听说过“诚实的艾布”(Chéngshí de Àibù) 这个绰号，他是美国第16任总统。
他于1865年遇刺身亡。
你或许可以将他与另一位著名的领导人相比较。你知道这位是谁吗？
是的，弗朗西斯科·莫拉桑 (Fúlǎngxīsīkē Mòlāsāng)。
弗朗西斯科·莫拉桑。好的，他们不尽相同，但都是非常受欢迎的总统，对吧？
是的，没错。
所以我们要讨论的问题是：怎样才算一个好的领导者？
花一分钟思考一下，然后你可以和我分享并讨论这个问题。
在你看来，怎样才算一个好的领导者？
好的。
您是希望我写下来还是可以直接开始说？
嗯，你可以直接说。
我认为好的领导者不仅能鼓舞人心，而且知道何时该采取行动。
好的。
嗯，同意。是具有主动性的人，对吧？
是的，完全正确。
我认为这两位领导者都曾鼓舞他人，并展现出卓越的主动性。
我同意。
他们两人也都参与了一些伟大的自由主义改革。
好了，这里列出了一些可以帮助我们提高英语水平，特别是读写能力，当然还有口语能力的方法，因为我们整个课程都会进行对话。
这些是我们的课程目标。
你能从这里第一个开始，读一下课程目标吗？
是的。识别并解释《啊，船长！我的船长！》的历史背景。
定义关键词汇。
例如，
呃...挽歌 (wǎngē)？
龙骨 (lónggǔ)，严峻的考验 (yánjùn de kǎoyàn)，
或者它是
是挽歌 (wǎngē)。
以及识别并解释诗中的扩展隐喻 (kuòzhǎn yǐnyù)。
分析扩展隐喻 (kuòzhǎn yǐnyù)，解释船长、船、可怕的航行和奖赏分别代表什么。
讨论诗歌的基调，及其与悲伤和钦佩的关系。
并通过讨论和书面回答来表达对诗歌的理解。
好的。
哦，还有将诗歌中关于失落、领导力以及国家悲剧 (guójiā bēijù) 的主题与更广泛的自由概念联系起来。
是自由 (zìyóu) 吗？
比如自由。
是的。
哦，比如自由。
好了，我们有很多事情可以做。
我们可能没有时间做完所有这些，但关于这首诗，肯定有很多值得我们深入探讨 (shēnrù tàntǎo) 的地方。
还有，嗯，沃尔特·惠特曼以及这里的历史背景。
词汇可能有点过时，因为这首诗写于1865年，就在亚伯拉罕·林肯遇刺之后。
所以我希望你们在读这首诗的时候记住这一点。
这首诗是有背景的。
而且它可能在谈论一些更深层次的东西。
所以当我们说扩展隐喻 (kuòzhǎn yǐnyù) 时，你知道，隐喻是A指代B。
但是扩展隐喻可能是指整个段落或文本都在象征着某种东西。
好的。
这里有一些历史背景。
但首先，关于美国内战 (Měiguó Nèizhàn) 或亚伯拉罕·林肯，你知道些什么？
哦，我知道“诚实的艾布”这个绰号。
美国内战主要是关于奴隶制 (núlìzhì) 的，
如果我没记错的话，对吗？
是的。
北方和南方之间的战争。
然后是亚伯拉罕·林肯……
嗯，您说了他是第16任总统，但我想还有些什么……
我想他做了一个非常重要的决定，但我记不太清了。
他因此而真正闻名的事情。
《解放黑人奴隶宣言》(Jiěfàng Hēirén Núlì Xuānyán)。
是的。
没错。
好的。
非常好。
所以你对美国内战和这首诗的背景有所了解。
内战在美国是何等重要。
它不仅影响了美国，还对其他国家产生了连锁效应 (liánsuǒ xiàoyìng)。
并且确实改变了很多人的态度。
而且内战结束时，一切并没有结束。
至今仍未结束。
说真的，我们仍在与不平等作斗争。
我们仍在与世界各地与奴隶制相关的问题作斗争。
以及这个关于真正自由意味着什么的问题。
这仍然任重道远 (rènzhòngdàoyuǎn)。
所以沃尔特·惠特曼在1865年写下了《啊，船长！我的船长！》，这正是在两件大事发生后不久。
你能为我们读一下这部分吗？
当然。内战的结束，这场战争从1861年持续到1865年。
一场分裂了国家的残酷冲突 (cánkù chōngtū)。
以及1865年4月亚伯拉罕·林肯总统遇刺，就在南方邦联投降几天之后。
许多人将林肯视为引领国家这艘船的船长。
这艘船…驶过了战争这段可怕的航程。
所以我们已经看到了一个隐喻的例子：国家如船，他驾驶着它，他是船长。
在我们即将读到的这首诗中。
这里有另一张亚伯拉罕·林肯的彩色照片。
我觉得现在能给老照片上色真是太酷了。
让它看起来很真实。
还有一个场景，像是你会在报纸上看到的那样。
亚伯拉罕·林肯是在一家剧院被枪击并遇刺的。
好的。
这里有一些我们需要了解的术语。
对于这些词汇中的一些，你可能会有些犹豫。
它们有点难。
我们有抒情诗 (shūqíngshī)，挽歌 (wǎngē)，隐喻 (yǐnyù) 和扩展隐喻 (kuòzhǎn yǐnyù)。
抒情诗是表达个人情感或感受的诗歌。
通常以第一人称叙述。
所以我们即将读到的这首诗是抒情诗。
还有这个，记住发音，挽歌 (wǎngē)。你能为我们读一下这个吗？
是的。
一首严肃反思的诗，通常是为逝者写的哀歌。
《啊，船长！我的船长！》是为亚伯拉罕·林肯写的挽歌。
没错。
所以我们谈论的是一位被杀害的船长。
因此这首诗意境深远。
从某种意义上说，它有点黑暗。
你必须想象战争结束时的那种感觉。
战争结束时的感觉可能是一种解脱。
你可以想象，但同时也有巨大的悲伤。
你无法挽回逝去的生命。
你无法撤销已经发生的事情。
木已成舟 (mù yǐ chéng zhōu)。
我们有隐喻，这是一种修辞手法，将一个词或短语应用于……
所以当一事物是另一事物时，然后是它的延伸，即扩展隐喻。
你能为我们读一下这个吗？
是的。
一种在几行文字甚至整个作品中展开的隐喻。
很好。
这是第一次朗读。
这第一部分我来读。
我希望你仔细听听这听起来是怎样的。
众目睽睽紧随平稳的龙骨，
船只阴沉而无畏。
但是，哦，心啊，心啊，心啊！
哦，那鲜红的血滴，
在甲板上，我的船长躺在那里，冰冷地逝去。
所以我们看到了这艘带有龙骨 (lónggǔ) 的船的形象。
船的某个特定部分，对吧？
阴沉而无畏的船只。
你看到这艘阴暗的船驶入。